All right.
Lisandro Brill, thank you so much
for joining me on the show.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Pleasure.
It's so great to have you.
I'm so excited to learn as much as I can
over these next 20 minutes
about your so, so fascinating life.
As a journalist, television,
and then going on to venture capital.
You've made some incredible investments,
An expert on Latin America.
And I just want to hear as many stories
as I can fit into these 20 minutes.
Lisandro, take me back
to your days of journalism.
Who are you?
I studied economics
at the University of Buenos Aires
in Argentina and never
expected to be a journalist.
But I started as a journalist
in economic section
of a major newspaper, Argentina.
But I never want to be a journalist.
So, I made my degree at Harvard USA.
Afterwards came back to Argentina,
As everybody does, of course.
Well, there's a second-class University
there at the East Coast
of the United States.
Then I came back to Argentina
and I became unexpectedly
when I was 32 years old,
Undersecretary of State
for Foreign Trade for the nation.
And this was absolutely unexpected for me
after I graduated from Harvard.
And during my 10 years tenure
at the government,
I reached a conclusion that really
the problem that I was facing
Latin America was that there was not
investment capital for pushing the talent
of Latin America towards global markets.
And this was venture capital.
So, wait wait. Explain to me.
So, dumb it down for me.
You're sitting there.
You're working within the government,
You're overlooking what's happening.
And what is this realization again?
You realized that the innate problem
of the emerging markets is that
there's just not enough venture capital?
I would say that for emerging markets
that want to expand themselves
into value added products,
into innovation.
There was no venture capital.
Okay.
And I thought that venture capital
was a crazy idea that,
because when I was the student at Harvard,
there was a guy there that invented the
tools to do the simulation of the cases.
And so I plugged in his software,
was a classmate of mine
in my Apple II 1764K
This was in 1980.
And this was the invention
of the electronic spreadsheet.
It didn't exist the electronic spreadsheet.
This was invented as
under the name of BICS and CALP.
Yeah.
You were not born.
Nope.
Afterwards came MultiPlan.
After cames Lotus.
And Lotus was fantastic.
Because you could key
in your keyboard and transform
a bunch of numbers into
a graph interactively.
And this was Lotus.
I know this is all story.
Everybody now is under Excel.
But the concept of
electronic spreadsheet was invented
at a Harvard Business School.
Between a person that wanted
to save time in preparing the cases.
And a guy from MIT.
I crossed the river to the
Kennedy School of Government.
And imagine what happened.
There was a huge discussion there.
Huge discussion was,
well, listen, this was 1980.
Listen, who owns the patent?
And the discussion was the patent
should be owned.
One-third by the inventor.
One-third by the laboratory
of the Harvard University.
And one-third by the university endowment
as a whole.
And when this was fixed,
how to split the ownership of the patent,
the guy receiving millions of dollars
to develop a genome project.
So, I thought this is crazy ideas
that happen only in the States.
But I came back to Argentina,
Latin America.
I realized that even Latin America
wants to develop a different area
of innovative projects in technology.
We should join
the venture capital world.
And so, I started a venture capital
in 1989 when--
Lisandro, I just want to point out that,
we almost just went past it.
But you were sitting there working,
meeting and discussing entrepreneurship
with the person that invented the
technology behind the first spreadsheets.
But you were getting this inspiration.
And you're sitting and you're understanding.
Wow, all this entrepreneurial spirit
here in Cambridge.
Why don't we have
this in Latin America?
You arrived there in 1989.
What is the entrepreneurial scene
over there?
And what is the venture capital scene
when you go back over there?
Oh, Listen.
Venture capital didn't exist
in Latin America at all.
I'm one of the founders of Endeavour,
which is an NGO that promotes
entrepreneurship in Latin America.
Is the equivalent of a government foundation.
When this was invented, a rich one guy,
This was in 1998,
There wasn't entrepreneur.
Wow.
And so, a guy I was receiving
his office by the assistant.
And the assistant say, "Listen, there's here
a guy on the name of [Peter Kember],
[Alitha Rothenburg] from US
that comes with Lisandro Brill.
They want to do venture capital.
They are here with a backpack.
They are very nice people.
Very nice.
I do not want what they do.
It seemed that venture capital is
something like adventure tourism
in Patagonia, Latin America.
So, people didn't understand
a clue of what
venture capital was about.
And when I wanted to reach
A family office.
This happened to me also in 1992.
Explaining what venture capital.
That we have to do incubation
for startups.
After a 20-minute discussion.
The guy that was an older said,
"Listen, I still do not understand.
In this incubator
what kind of chicken you are growing?"
So, venture capital world
did not exist in Latin America.
I would say 1998 with all the boom
of the Internet that was developed
with E-commerce just blew out.
Right.
And so, I was able to raise my first fund.
My first one was underwritten by
Hicks Muse Tate & Furst out of Dallas, Texas.
They were in love with Argentina.
They love Buenos Aires.
They love entrepreneurial spirit.
They loved it.
I say, "How is it possible?"
We have to bring that right through there?
And this was their very
first venture capital firm, I would say,
in Latin America.
We invested $20 million.
And one of the first companies we invested
is very well known by you.
Because it came out
from Stanford University,
Founded by a guy on the name of
Marcos Galperin
who just did a copy of eBay, Amazon
and created MercadoLibre.
MercadoLibre today in Latin America,
which you saw only 6% or 7%
of Latin America is under e-commerce.
But today is valued $49 billion
and is just eating the market of retail
in the region.
Not only with e-commerce,
but also, with financial services.
So, this provides an example
that entrepreneurship can happen
this part of the world that can develop
if adequate funding is available.
Especially if you have funds.
And we see some GPs in partners
that know how to grow companies.
Of course.
And now you're actually co-founder
of the Latin America
segment of J-Ventures,
which were both a part of.
Correctly. Because my family
came from prosecutive,
from programs
from Ukraine in 1905.
So, there is a Jewish community of
250 thousand peoples
third after US in America is
the following community of Jewish people.
I belong to this community
and I was very much really
motivated by the vision of
Oded Hermoni,
Laura Laver and Jim Cosman
to connect the diaspora of us people
to help develop our threat in our
community with the activity
of doing business.
Which is the same thing
that my father did in 1950s.
I remember my father
when he used to go around
the world doing business in trade.
I said, "Father, but you don't speak English."
And he said, "Well, it is the belief."
"Because I do speak English."
Do you trust my English?
Yes. Yes, I do.
So, he created businesses.
Because he knocked on
with the Jewish community
around the world.
Is an old tradition of our community. Yes.
Okay, Lisandro,
give me your insight
into the Latin America entrepreneurial
and venture capital scene today.
Coming in from Israel
and from the US,
I don't get exposed too much
to what's happening in Latin America.
And the closest I've been there
is to go around and meet
entrepreneurs and VCs in Mexico,
to try and get a little bit of the taste
of what are the challenges
of emerging markets.
Because is it considered
an emerging market,
a developing market
that is still not matured yet?
I'm assuming it is.
But I just want to make sure.
Venture capital is embryonic
in Latin America.
It's very easy.
Latin America is 600 million people.
50% is Brazil.
That's you speak Portuguese.
50% is Spanish
speaking Latin America.
And the most important countries are
Brazil and Portuguese, Mexico, Argentina,
Colombia, and afterwards, the rest.
So, venture capital is
starting Latin America.
By far the most important
country is Brazil.
We have minimum 30 funds in Brazil.
Very much supported originally
by the government.
But also, by the
investors from the Silicon Valley.
You have Kaszek, Monashees,
Redpoint are the names
of the games here.
In Mexico I am a partner
with AltaVentures, and Dalus capital.
They are based there a venture partner in Dallas
and is a smaller country.
But I would say that Brazil and Mexico are
the two only countries in Latin America
that can develop
the J-curve of venture capital.
That means companies domestically
that can grow
to the size of being big plays.
So, for example, we have
our most famous case may be a NuBank.
That is $40 billion market cap.
Is a FinTech company in Brazil.
But you have a Didi's,
which is the Uber originally of Brazil
that was sold to Didi
in China for a billion dollars.
And you have in Mexico
companies such as Clip
That is a square,
In the US, they are valued well above
about half a billion dollars today.
And of course,
this is a part of the story,
which is deals basically with IT.
With software.
I am not pushing a lot,
bringing Israeli technologies and
Silicon Valley technologies
invested by J-Ventures to Latin America
in the AgriFood tech space.
You have a nice company there
in J-Ventures based in Monteview
of Palo Alto on the name of Big Hero
that is trying to enter Latin America.
Because they do colonization
and they increase
the productivity of crops by 30%.
Incredible.
I think how much contribution
you can make to food security
around the world.
And saving these around the world. Yeah.
Of course. Of course. Of course.
And Argentina and Brazil are great
places for crop production.
We can feed in the world
minimum two billion people.
And we are only, let's say,
200 million people,
250 million people inhabitant.
So, we have the capacity
because you have the technology there.
You have the artificial intelligence.
But in order to embed proteins
into something that is called food,
you need land and water so far.
And Israel and California have land or
water to feed and create these proteins.
This is being done here in South America
as a major destination.
So, what do you just,
I just want to clarify.
You just said that Latin America
there are places that accumulates
to about the population
of 200 million.
But the land and the potential
is to grow food
that can feed two billion?
Yes, I yes.
Because Argentina's a country of
40 million people,
has land and water
with adequate technology
to feed the billion people.
It sounds like a gold mine.
It sounds like these places
have so much incredible potential
that why are entrepreneurs
wasting their time here in Palo Alto
building in new social apps
for millions of people?
If they can go to Latin America
and work on problems
that can feed billions.
It sounds like it's a much better idea
to go to Latin American
and do technology there, no?
Well, it's an untapped continent.
So, I would say that our role,
your role Matias,
is the role of J-Ventures,
It's exactly to connect
these communities,
with the philosophy of Ticuna land.
Yes, of course,
As Oded like to say
Oded Hermoni likes to say,
as Laura Logan likes to say,
as Ronald Cohen likes to say,
That we listened to him last week.
And of course, there is a lot of opportunity
in as much as you bother with people
that know how to cope
with our characteristics.
Because you take a New York guy
that went to Harvard or to Stanford
and he lands in Be'er Sheva
and he lands in Tel Aviv.
I am sure that he will not go
with their shoes holds back.
[--]
He would have to adapt.
He would have to partner.
So, I would say that the secret
is to have a global thinking,
to capture opportunity.
And you have the knowledge
and experience to act locally,
to deliver globally.
Wonderful. Okay, Lisandro,
So, you know, I came to Stanford
from my military service.
A lot of my friends went to go
do startups and go work.
But I felt that I didn't understand
what are the biggest problems
that the world needs to be solved?
And what are the biggest things
in Ticuna land that I can do
that are both profitable,
but also have a great
net positive impact for the world.
And so, I'm taking up on this offer.
I'm finishing here--
If it's about food.
It's about health.
It's about housing.
Okay. So, Lisandro the deal is that
I'm finishing up this degree here
and then I'm coming to Latin America,
I'm taking you as a mentor
and you're showing me
how I can use deep technology
to solve big problems in your continent.
More than welcome. I am in debt of you.
OK. Wonderful.
Okay, Lisandro, amazing.
We have this on record,
So, this is fantastic.
But I want to spend the next five minutes
or so talking about your passions.
What are you truly excited about
as an investor, as an entrepreneur,
as a thinker, as a Ticuna lawmaker?
My passion is human development
and progress.
What does that mean?
Human development and progress
is to live in a world
where basic needs
in terms of nutrition,
15 [--] calories per person.
Education.
15 years of education, guaranteed
Health.
Access to health as you have in Israel.
[--]
They are in California.
And let's say 25 square meters per
person for living
Once you have these,
you are assured that you have the freedom
to choose and become a free person.
A citizen of the world.
I love this.
And do you know who invented
this concept of developing economics
with these human development approach?
This was invented in Silicon Valley
by a guy who was a human psychologist
on the name Maslow.
I was just about to say
the Maslow pyramid,
which talks about this idea
that you need the foundations
before you can reach fulfillment.
So, my passion is to connect
venture capital with it.
Abraham Maslow pyramid,
To develop human needs.
To push for human freedom
on a global scale.
And this is the only, in my judgment,
a guarantee for security.
Wow. Unbelievable.
So, does that guide
your investment strategy
and the types of projects
that you're working on?
Obviously, you're taking up your precious
time and you're working also
with the J-Ventures, an early stage fund.
But is this from in the mindset of
I'm going to take on projects that have
the potential to reach meaningful
net positive outcomes on human lives?
I am always fascinated by impact investing.
During the 90s, early this century,
impact investing, the name of the game was
creating great companies,
creating big companies
and creating Endeavor, my NGO
that we invented in Argentina.
Now we are in 25 countries
around the world
to promote economic development.
But as of today I will say that creating
this world has not been enough.
Now we have applied to this technology
to which called impact investing,
which is what we have heard.
J-Ventures from
Ronald Cohen.
Yes.
About the environment sustainable
that have inclusion potential
to feed people, to nurture people,
to provide for health.
And no doubt that food tech
and health tech
would be major areas of investment.
Because for me, the offices,
institutional investors,
are pushing
the venture capital private equity industry
to invest in the things that make
the world more sustainable.
100%. Lisandro,
That's just so inspiring to hear.
Before we leave and I can't believe
20 minutes are almost up.
We have just a minute left.
But I want to know your three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
And I'd love an explanation about them,
because I think that your
your mindset is fascinating.
Your ambitions are incredible.
And I just love this notion of going
through your journey both as
an entrepreneur, venture capital,
you non-government worker.
With the mindset of improving humanity
and freeing the people
from the shackles of a food,
of water, of health, of living.
So, please Lisandro,
three words that best describe you.
Passion for human development,
fellow for world security.
Ticuna land.
Okay. So, ticuna land.
It's all about that.
It's all about that impact. Right?
Right.
Okay. Lisandro one tip
that you would give me
or any other entrepreneur
that starting their journey.
Impact investing and Ticuna land
is not necessarily in the mindset
of every young entrepreneur today
going into this world.
So what is one thing that I should
keep in mind as I go through my path?
Travel.
Know the world.
Connect deeply
with the people around the world.
Because you have a fantastic background
coming from Israel.
You can connect your world.
The Stanford world with these people.
And we are now sure that we
live in a global system where
everything is interconnected.
It's the time of the pandemics of covid.
It's the time that people realize
that we are in one world
and we have to connect
to each other in a positive sum game.
100%, 100%.
Lisandro, toda raba.
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you for the inspiration.
Thank you for everything you're doing.
And I'm gonna see you on Latin America
when we worked together.
Come here more than welcome.
Of course. Take care Lisandro
Thank you very much.
Bye bye.